Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in surah al
verse number
18 and 19. Last night we spoke a little
bit about verse number 17
and that is the statement of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala how then
will you shield yourselves and protect
yourselves
from the punishment of Allah is what is
inferred
if you disbelieve
or how may you protect yourselves if you
disbelieve from the punishment of a day
which will turn and render even infants
white-haired from its horrors.
What's interesting about this verse is
that
the recitation that most of us are
familiar with and listen to. There's
actually
another way to recite this verse which
adds another layer of meaning.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
Notice the difference. The difference is
what
went from
that's it.
instead of
the original meaning.
How then will you protect yourselves
from a day
which is so horrific that it will render
even infants white-haired from its
horrors if you disbelieve. That is the
meaning.
But if we make that second recitation
from that,
it then becomes what?
How then will you protect yourselves
from me if you disbelieve?
So now Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is from
in one place saying, "How will you
protect yourselves from that day?" In
the second recitation, it becomes, "How
then will you protect yourselves from me
on that day?"
And this really joins the different
places in the Quran where Allah uses in
that way in his linguistic sense.
Sometimes
he says,
"Protect and shield yourselves from
Allah." In other places he says, up,
shield yourselves from the fire.
Those two things mean that when we
protect ourselves with tawa,
we are really not protecting ourselves
from all of Allah's names and
attributes. We are only seeking
protection from the anger of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, from the punishment
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And this
verse with that fat or kas it unites
both meanings. How then will you protect
yourselves from the punishment of that
day? How then will you protect
yourselves from me on that day?
If you disbelieve, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says, notice here how he says,
how are you going to protect yourselves
from me if you disbelieve?
Subhan Allah. And this is one of the
seven reasons why we have different
recitations of the Quran. If we didn't
have multiple recitations of the Quran,
this book would probably be six or seven
times the size that it actually is.
Because by making that subtle change,
reciting it with a fat and then also
reciting it with a with teaching the
prophet Sam.
Now there are two verses in one with
just the difference of a fat or a and
this is all through the Quran. This is
one of the miracles of the Quran that it
is able to tolerate and take on so many
meanings with just one with just one way
of writing it.
and we notice that
most of the recitations of the Quran
which are correct which are which are or
we notice that
Most of these recitations, 99% of them
do not affect the way that the word is
written at all. It's just an issue of
how it is pronounced. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala then says in the next verse
speaking about the day of judgment. Now,
what is one of the reasons why a an
infant would turn gray? His hair would
turn gray. Allah describes it as a day
when
she
righte here is plural for the word
meaning someone whose hair is not just
white it is cotton white all of it
entirely not just a little bit gray
It is completely white.
And so what would cause an infant
to turn their hair white? I would ask
you,
what do we associate with white hair?
When we see someone with white hair,
what is the co what are the causes that
could be a person has white hair?
Wisdom.
So wherever there's white hair, there's
wisdom.
[Arabic recitation]
contain the wisdom? The wisdom is just
too much. Is just is just coming out out
of his pores. Is that what it is?
[Arabic recitation]
why a person's hair would be white.
That's one here in this verse. What's
another one?
[Arabic recitation]
probably is genetics, but that doesn't
matter for us for our purposes here. So,
we have fear and we have what? Old age.
Notice how the wording is ambiguous.
The day of judgment. How long is it?
500 years. I wish. How long is the day
of judgment?
50,000
years.
So this mention of the white hair,
infants hair turning white is because of
the horrors of the day of judgment. But
it's also because of what?
Because of what? The length of the day
of judgment. So this one description
here
holds two meanings that the day of
judgment is very frightening and the day
of judgment is very what long is very
long. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
articulates this by saying
that
the heavens the the sky is splitting
apart
because of the anticipation of the day
of judgment.
Now when we look at the word,
this comes from the root word,
right? And Allah says this and says
meaning when
the sky splits.
has a number of meanings
that if we were to look at for
instance
all of these different words in Arabic
that hold the same general meaning there
are subtle differences.
One of the meanings of
Is
that a split, this is the visual you're
supposed to be getting in your mind
here,
is that this split seemingly comes from
nowhere. It is not a split that starts
at the seams of something. It starts in
the middle of it and it comes out
because of stress. most usually. What do
I mean by that? If I were to have like
for instance this clothing that I have
on, you see here the seams. These this
is the weakest part of the fabric. The
seams where I have two pieces of fabric
that I'm sewed together
is not it coming apart here at the
seams. And then fur would be when the
fabric comes apart from a place that has
no seams, has no
has no place where it would logically
begin. The only reason this clothing
would split open that is because of
what?
Because of stress that is placed on the
fabric, not because the stitches are
weak. So if you imagine with me for
instance that I have a book this book
here this this square al would start in
the middle here it would open this
and split lengthwise or this way it
wouldn't start at the edge at the weak
point it would start in the middle do we
understand that and this is why one of
Allah's names is what
What does mean?
Why does that detail matter that I just
told you right now?
Well, what does the name mean?
The opener
is
the originator, right? The creator of
the heavens and the earth. But is
different than
because means the creator but means the
one who creates something from nothing.
Do you notice the reason why it's
important that when we look at the word
that the split that I just gave you, the
proverbial split, it doesn't come from
the seams. It doesn't come from the
edges. It doesn't come from the sides.
It starts in the very middle seemingly
from nowhere and it splits open. This is
called inar.
Why? Because of the imagery of it
starting from seemingly nothing.
And that is why Allah's name is F. It
doesn't just mean the creator. It means
the creator of something from nothing.
Subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
And this is where we get the all of the
other subsequent derivatives of this
word. So for instance when a person
breaks his fast it is called what
right or why because they are breaking
something and splitting something that
is otherwise connected with
which is abstinence with taking in food.
right etc. There are many derivatives of
of the word and and so forth. And so
when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
what does that mean? That means that the
imagery that should be going through
your mind is if we were all looking at
the sky, it seems perfect and then
suddenly right in the very middle it
splits open
and it's almost like
[Arabic recitation]
It implies that something splits from
the center.
equal siding and so forth.
The most important the most
important distinction
between
is that begins in the middle seemingly
from nowhere and it is sudden.
Okay, this is the meaning of
so when we have for instance two
chapters of the Quran
Right?
If I were going to translate those two,
I'd translate them the same way,
right? However,
if I were to dive into the deep
nuances of the differences of the
meanings,
would mean that it splits suddenly from
the very center. Whereas an in just
means that it is a lengthwise split down
the middle. That's what an inch is. Do
we understand the differences there? So
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
meaning that the heavens
are
to split from the
pressure or the stress of anticipation
of the day of judgment
or on the day of judgment they will
split. Both meanings are correct because
meaning that right now the heavens are
almost going to split apart because of
their anticipation of the day of
judgment. Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he says about the day of judgment
right
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that the day of judgment it is heavy
it's knowledge it's almost the
inanimate objects around us the universe
verse is all heavy with dread because
it's almost it's all aware that the
day of judgment is approaching.
And so everything around us, the ground,
the heavens above us are almost going to
split apart because of the anticipation
of that day that is swiftly approaching.
Also on the day of judgment, we know
that the heavens will be split, split
open. They won't just be split from the
sides. We will be staring at the center
of the sky one moment and the next
moment suddenly it is split apart into
ribbons.
Now I have a question here for the Arab
speakers amongst us. What is strange
about the the the word?
What's strange about that statement?
Something strange about it.
[Arabic recitation]
or female. You know, Arabic is all male
and female. Everything is masculine and
feminine. There is no neutrality we
have in English. Everything is male and
female. Everything is referred to as
male or female. Now, in order for us to
understand this, sometimes in the Quran,
Allah will use male in the female place
and female in the male place. Why? For a
very important reason. For instance,
is that male or female?
Huh? It's male, right?
You would expect it to be what?
Is the verb. The verb is supposed to be
female just the just the
is is female or vice versa. But you
don't mix male and female together. You
don't give a a noun a female verb, a
male noun, a female verb, and you don't
give a female noun a male verb unless
there's a reason for it.
Why do we have inems
instead of
no nation of Tammud? What meanings come
from that? the Arabs.
In order for us to understand this, we
have to understand something about the
Arab culture, the language that
expresses that culture. In the Arab
culture and in the Arab language,
male has certain traits and female have
certain traits.
Male has the traits of strength,
resilience, robustness.
Female has the strength has the traits
of delicacy,
weakness,
beauty, poise, things that. Each
of them have their various
their various meanings that are
particular to the gender.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is using
which is male giving it a female verb
saying that belied
their their messenger.
[Silence]
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is speaking
about the argument that used with their
messenger. Their argument was one of
extreme weakness. It was a very purile
argument. It was only a veneer of
disbelief in their hearts. They knew
that
was their messenger that he was telling
the truth, but they rejected it anyways.
Here we have the opposite going on. We
have a seat which is female
being described with a male verb.
Why? Again, what does masculine carry?
The meaning of the the main difference
between masculine and feminine in Arabic
is strength and weakness. Correct?
The male carries the meaning the
connotations of strength. So Allah is
describing the female
noun
with male meaning that this heaven
is being split apart with extreme
violence and strength due to the
due to the great anticipation of the
coming and impending ing doom that the
day of judgment brings with it.
Then he says
Allah's word and decree is what
it is. It's as if it's already said and
done. And this is why we find that Allah
speaks about the day of judgment often
in past tense.
He speaks about the day of judgment
which is in the future in the past
tense. Why? Because it is so definite
and so surely to happen that it might as
well be have already been in the past.
That is how certain it is. And also to
us it's in the future to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. these constraints of time and
observation is not the same for for
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala. We will stop
there inshallah for tonight. We'll
continue this continue this what
Wednesday because I'm off tomorrow.
Tomorrow is my day off. She takes days
off. This is this is a sign of the
times, right? Okay.
Subhanahu
subhanahua.
[Silence]
I completely lost track of time.